Vladimir zielinski the president of
Ukraine has just come out and announced
that he's not going to have elections
the the basic element of a democracy
this guy's not going to do unless he
said he's willing to consider holding
elections if the United States pays for
it
zielinski said I told Senator Graham
okay I can't I can't do a Ukrainian
accent I can't even really do a Russian
he says I told Senator Graham if the
United States and Europe give us
financial support I'm sorry I will not
hold elections on credit I will not take
money from weapons and give it to
elections either but if you give me this
financial support if the
parliamentarians realize that we need to
do this then let's quickly change the
legislation and most importantly let's
take risks together
but no
otherwise I'm not holding these
elections now I get it I get why a
nation at War would not hold elections I
get why Vladimir zielinski has declared
martial law they're at War it's an
existential fight and also it was never
about democracy